[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting
we're talking about
your legacy
what you know when you go to a funeral
um sometimes as i did recently you s you
it puts these things on the forefront of
your mind thinking about like man
when i pass
how am i going to be remembered
and is there something
that i should be doing
now
in order to facilitate
my memory or my legacy the first thing
that comes to mind is you should be
trying to find a way to get that image
of you peeing chocolate into my mouth
off of the internet before you die yes i
and i do want to talk about
um and i'm and i should actively also be
working together that should be our only
goal let's just stop this podcast right
now i do want to talk about us as a
special case
in this but you know what
maybe you're not an internet celebrity
maybe you're just an avid listener of
two internet celebrities and that's okay
you still need to tackle
your legacy and how you want to be
remembered as anything you can do so i
think we can put ourselves in the shoes
of the listener as well and talk about
that um because yeah i've i have been in
this
in in
in this mode of okay
passing away
remembering you're in the mode of
passing away i'm pleased
i'm not passing away i mean technically
we all are slowly um
yeah i went to a funeral i'm i'm in the
headspace
good good word of passing away and being
remembered so i just thought you know
let's have a conversation about that so
i think the first half is
me sharing the experience of everything
surrounding this funeral and of course
uh you know i'm keeping it vague because
once i get once i start telling you
about it i'll be telling you about it
and then i do think that there's a
specific discovery
that then really got me thinking
about all of this stuff
more than just a funeral
okay more than just what other people
say about you after you die and a lot
more about what you say about yourself
after you die
okay talk about holograms now
you're intrigued
see all this was teaser
pretty light-hearted teaser i mean i
guess it's going to start out kind of
heavy you know if you don't want to hear
about passing the loved ones and
uh
funerals this is not the episode for you
or role-playing your own death that's
not i'm not saying that the right way
either
anyway proceed
um
all right hard left turn into into being
serious um
as as you know i've talked about it i
know you know but as i've talked about
on ear biscuits
my mom's husband louis
has not been good good good for a long
time of course that's that was his catch
phrase
but then once he suffered a number of
strokes about three years ago
we never heard him say good good good
anymore
um
and
as i i believe after i went home
in july i came back in and talked about
it on an ear biscuit like my my whole
experience of going home and
if it wasn't that episode it was another
one where i was just really inspired by
my mom
being so
sacrificial in her love for lewis to
take care of him 24 7
as as a nurse as well as a wife and
companion
for
yeah what what went on for three years
um he had a number of health
complications recently and we were you
know we were tracking along with mom
and
it's it
it was a bit of a surprise
when he passed
um
but it was he he had taken a turn so
there was like there were a few days
maybe a week leading up to it you know
he got
he had some complications from covid uh
he had a number of
other things going on but
the long and short of it is
um
he
he did pass away
you know and uh i never i never called
louis my my stepdad because again he got
married dude mom you did call him your
father-in-law
yeah i always called him a father-in-law
because i loved him so much i definitely
loved him and you know your stepdad is
not
yeah endearing enough yeah i know i'm
not feeling that term there should be a
term for when your stepdad steps up and
becomes your dad
and i think you just go he didn't become
my dad either okay he just he became
because you were an adult already he
became my mom's husband after that's how
you're always referred to him my mom's
husband right it would be like your
stepdad right and that that's not to say
that i didn't love him and still do love
him and he was a a popeye to
my kids
you know as well as a wonderful
wonderful husband
to my mom i mean
they loved each other i mean it the
reason why
and you know what i i they gave people
an opportunity to to stand up at the
funeral and say
um say a little something
about louis
and i i got up and
i just
and i and i have a firsthand account of
this well secondhand account because
yeah you weren't there my wife was there
yeah that's right because my wife
happened to be in north carolina at the
time which was awesome yeah she was
there talked to her beforehand she said
link did great
just in case you did you you had any
doubts about that well i knew there was
going to be like a popcorn sharing time
and
and i knew that i would i was ready to
go first so that to prime the pump for
other people to go
because they didn't might not have known
and been prepared for it you know it's
not walk up and go behind the podium and
just stand up and stand up where you are
because
the family
just felt like
that would give people an opportunity to
say something from the heart but not put
anybody on the spot who really needed to
prepare no no microphones there was a
microphone a passive mic so i knew that
this was going to happen and so i was
ready to kind of prime the pump so i i
i stood up first and said my little
piece and then other people said their
thing but i did a very calculated
i'm not going to ramble on forever
because then other people will feel like
they have to do that and a lot of me
getting up and
the
the main reason i'm getting up is
obvious but a secondary reason i'm
getting up is to empower other people to
share with us on their heart by not
being
too long or too perfect or intimidating
or anything i'm just going to be myself
and keep it simple
okay
but also keep it quick and that was the
one thing that i knew could be a problem
how long did you go
longer than i wanted but i mean i think
it ended up being like i don't i it felt
like
four minutes so it was probably six
minutes uh probably seven and a half and
it could have been seven and a half but
like jesse told you you did great i did
great right but i i was really glad to
celebrate
he and mom's relationship and the things
that i had already shared with you and
shared on this podcast um
that
it
really was a representation of you know
a fulfillment of the marriage vows they
took in in in sickness and in health
till death do us part you know she was
she was there with him she went
above and beyond not as a wife but as a
nurse really to
to to really to care for him when she
had lost so much of him
years ago i mean it was it's been so
difficult
to to see both of them go through this
but i say you know what she didn't do it
as a fulfillment of her vows
she did it because
she she loved him i mean they had a
great relationship they had a great life
together
they enjoyed each other
and it was it's a beautiful thing
that
he was the way the way he treated her
and the companionship they gave each
other he was
he was worthy of the care that she gave
him and that was the way that i wanted
to honor him to
his his family and friends
there was to say
i'm celebrating my mom for what she did
in service to him out of love not not
out of obligation
and
i'm so glad that she had someone in her
life that was worthy of that type of
care and sacrifice
because
lewis was
an awesome guy he was loved by everybody
in the community that's why other people
wanted to say something
and so
i mean it was the service was was really
beautiful and it was
it was a celebration it made all of us
feel
very
grateful to have had him in our lives i
will also say
another note that i got from jesse about
this funeral i didn't know if you were
going to talk about this aspect of it
um
we've been to many uh
christian
maybe only christian funerals
uh in our in our lives and i know that
this was a christian funeral and they
went to a methodist church yeah
many of the funerals that we went to
growing up
um
the obligate it was much less about the
person and they made it about the people
in the audience and about them having to
make a decision about jesus and it
became this very hardcore like gospel
presentation yeah and it was kind of
like yeah he was a great dude but
what about you and where are you going
to spend eternity and we always felt
like it wasn't a real funeral if the
pastor didn't take that hard turn into a
gospel presentation yeah um and i was
happy the the the current rhett
not maybe the old rep but the current
was very happy to hear that
while
you know obviously it was a christian
message
but it was really a celebration of his
life yeah and remembering him it was it
was
i believe it was honoring to god and
honoring to
his faith
um but it but it was and it was also
honoring to his life and it wasn't
putting the congregation on the spot in
any way which can
can feel kind of cringey
yeah um so yeah it it it
was
someone's death
for the sake of an agenda
i'll get off my soapbox but i'm just
happy to yeah then that didn't happen
pastor
did a great job
and everybody else who talked including
me apparently
yeah they did great
the pastor did great i mean come to
think of it she didn't say anybody
didn't do great
so
yeah
everybody did great right
that's not really what it was about
but sure
um but
the
the experience around it was one that i
wouldn't trade for the world because
uh
lewis passed away on a wednesday evening
and then
i got on a plane the next morning to fly
home to be with mom so by the within 22
hours of his passing
i was there with mom so he died on a
wednesday night um and then
i
was able to get on plane the next
morning and fly home so that about 22
hours later
i was there with my mom
and
the
we actually had plans
to like as a family we were coming in we
had already made plans a long time ago
to come into town the following weekend
for britain's wedding which was like
basically in the same in the you know in
the next town over yeah in sanford
so we were like okay we all need to be
here for the funeral we may not be able
to make the wedding
um
but
the
it worked out
and with with the family and the funeral
home and everything to push the funeral
to the following thursday so he died on
wednesday i arrived the next day one
week later is when we scheduled the
funeral so that my family could come
into town go to the funeral
and then stay through the wedding as
opposed to
missing the wedding because we couldn't
do both if it was earlier because they
would
and be in jeopardy of missing too much
school
so logistically we work that out
but a
a byproduct of that and that's just
something that
uh i'll end up
treasuring forever i think
is it meant that i was with my mom for
six days
like all day
and then staying at her house
all night
until
christy and the kids showed up and then
we went to an airbnb for the night
before the funeral um
and that turned out to be you know it
was great to be able to be there for mom
and for it not to be something that was
rushed it's like you know when
when a loved one dies across the country
it's like when you go out there but then
you got to get back to your life and you
can't you can't keep doing a lot of your
work and
uh so you got to go back versus like if
you're in town you can show up and leave
and
you know with us being over here it's
just one of those times where it really
it really hurts to not be there because
you can't be there for the people that
you love the most
so it was nice that it worked out
and
it was actually easier because
it was
this that same week as the week that you
were on that trip with lock so the same
time that you were doing that that's why
jesse was there but you weren't there
um
if anybody's wondering that
and it made it easier logistically our
shooting schedule was kind of cleared
and it ended up
in it so i really felt released
from my work in a way that i i think i
would have made the right decision to be
with mom anyway
maybe that whole time but i just felt
more i didn't have the pressure of like
okay there's
there's so much that runs through the
two of us i always get scared and it's
like to do the right thing it's going to
make things really hard back here for
work
so it was nice to be released from that
because
it just so happened you were already
gone that week yeah
um
and i helped mom walk through
a lot of the logistics and working with
lewis's family to like
i don't just to set things up keep
things clean around the house you know
my mom's an only child
i'm an only child so it's like
when it comes to her and our side of the
family
it's and it's really just the two of us
you know there's nobody else who's going
to come in and help my mom out
except for
a couple of her
best friends
who are going to be in and out
so i
i did really need to step up
so i was able to do that but every night
you know people were coming through all
throughout the day it was really
every night
people would stop showing up when it got
dark and it would just be the two of us
hanging out like
watching television eating some eating
some more of that bojangles that
everybody was dropping off like that's
what people do man oh man it was great
bojangles has this like cinnamon twist
thing now it's like bow berry biscuits
are not as good as this cinnamon twist
thing okay people were bringing these
cinnamon twists by that might be
sacrilegious i'm just planting a seed
man
nothing with cinnamon in it is better
than a blueberry biscuit it's just
oh it's so good okay but i had both
so we'd be
we'd be eating some of that of course i
did go to the uh grocery store and buy
my supplies which were um
uh water chapstick coffee
and cereal
so i get me a bowl of cereal and i'd sit
down there with my mom your mom's not a
coffee drinker
no so i got to make sure i got my coffee
wow
she's never been a coffee drinker nope
and then
we would just sit down and talk
every night of course we would talk you
know she'd be processing
like this slowly becoming real you know
you're in shock it's like even you might
think it was expected but it it wasn't
and you really can't
fully expect to you know to lose your
your mate right so
you can't be fully prepared for that
yeah so whenever she wanted to talk
about
louis
and
in like memories or
you know what they had just been going
through it's like you know i was just
able to to listen but then we would also
talk about other things i was like i
brought up stuff that like
memories from my childhood that i was
talking about in therapy
like i would bring up i was like mom i
remember this thing i'm not gonna share
it here but
um
yeah i kind of got her perspective on
it like
uh
i don't care i'll share it i remember
when i was a kid
i would i wrote like one of my first
memories was at first baptist church
i got it was me and jimmy my step dad he
was legitimate your father
now my father-in-law
your first father-in-law i remember in
the middle of the service i was doing
something he took me out of the service
and like walked down the center island
took me out and like gave me a lecture
and like and then brought me back in to
like apologize to my mom during the
service i don't even remember what i was
doing but i remember just kind of being
traumatized by the fact that like i was
paraded out in the middle of church
while ever and back in while everybody
was looking at
and it was like he didn't whoop you
though he didn't want me
um
and mom reminded me well when you came
back in you you had a
you had a flower in your hand you'd
picked a flower
and you and came and gave it to me and i
was like that's like four years old wow
five years old at most
and she was like reminding me of that
pick a flower for your mama boy and she
was like i don't care just to get one
she gave me some insight into what was
going on there that like we had never
talked about we had this very adult
conversation about like
what was it like so many things that
like
experiences like these little bits of
memories that you have when you're a
child
that i never sat down and picked my
mom's brain on
what what was happening that what did i
do wrong
she remember
she said i couldn't sit still and she
thought that the punishment didn't fit
the crime
so it was there was a bit of vindication
there
um
but that's just the nature of the type
of conversations that we ended up having
to the point where i was like on this
maybe it was the first night or second
night i just turned to mom and i was
like you know
um
this is the first time that we've ever
spent this much time together just the
two of us
since
definitely before i got married like
once i got married it's like i'm always
bringing christy it's like hey worry you
know we're i'm not coming and spending
the night with my mom once i'm a married
man
you know it just doesn't happen well i
mean right in some relationships it
happens yeah but
not in yourself yeah
i'm i'm grateful for that and it's like
you know and we never
so and back when we did live together we
were never having
adult conversations
right you know
um so
it was
it was nice to be there for her but also
to kind of have this
like to develop this
new rapport
between the two of us another time i i
just kind of got in my mind
questions i would ask her
because it's and i will clarify it's not
that we weren't
close but
growing up it was just that
um
most people don't talk to their parents
yeah she loves i mean
my mom was the sweetest mom i can't come
up with any trash to talk about her to
my therapist i'll put it to you that way
you know she never actively did anything
to me that i could that i i need to pay
for therapy for
like i could say that honestly
um
but yeah it's it's not like uh in
college i called her every and talked to
her on the phone all the time we had
this like dynamic relationship
but we we've always had a good
relationship
um
but this was kind of like a different
level and a different facet to it
which was
surprising it's like i started coming up
with questions to ask her like
mom what are you
what do you think about me being famous
just to kind of get it just just to get
a kick out of how she and she was like
why are you asking me that she's like
she's like getting paranoid like well
do you think i'm not proud of you i'm
like no no i know you're proud of me
it's just like
did you do you is it weird do you is it
weird
do you actually know that i'm actually
she was like well i know that you're
famous
i do know that i mean i go to the
grocery store and
people people people always have
something to say about you and rhett
and i'm like okay so you don't really
you don't really know i don't have well
what i got to take my mom somewhere to
like prove my fame i don't know what it
is like when dad came out there that
time when we had the buddy system
billboard
we took i took him out on hollywood
boulevard and was like look up there see
that billboard that's me
in hollywood like that kind of did it
for my dad of course he definitely knows
i'm famous you know that's what
but that's the type of conversations
that that mom and i were having
and at some point in the conversation
i remembered
as we were talking about lewis i was
like you know what
louis
mentioned to me mom do you know this
i think he said in front of you too that
he was
writing
down his life story or i don't know what
how he put it i don't know if he said
i'm writing on my life story but in my
mind it was like
oh louis is writing a memoir
it's kind of how i processed it and she
was like
yes
i would give him such a hard time about
that oh really he said i'm he's he said
i'm gonna write a book like so many
things have happened to me i'm gonna
write a book and i i and mom said
and now i just kind of i feel kind of
bad for him because i just gave him a
hard time about it i was like so you so
you never read it she was like no
and it was like but the way that lewis
talked about what he wrote was or that
what he was writing
was i'm just writing down some stories
from
you know i got these stories things that
happened to me i'm writing them down
and um so he would
he would downplay he didn't say you know
i'm right i'm i'm writing and going to
publish a book and i know i sound like
bill clinton but well so does he there's
a little bit of you sound like lewis to
me okay
good
um
so i went on his computer
and i guess it was not password
protected uh
no
and i just started well if you're going
to write a memoir and not keep it in the
cloud then don't put a password on your
computer i don't think he has a cloud
exactly
the cloud is
the computer yeah lewis didn't have a
cloud
um
i remember at the time and this was
maybe a couple of years ago that he
mentioned this that
um
i was thinking
wow this
if he's really following through with
this and he seems serious about it this
is something that
one day when he does pass
this will be something this would be a
nice thing to have maybe he's writing it
for his kids or
you know i haven't read it and he didn't
say who he was writing it for but like
that thought entered my mind and kind of
stuck in there and then it popped back
in
and i was like oh man yeah this is
he's been working on this thing
i know not in the past three years but
before that he said he was working on it
you know so
um
i went on his computer
and i'll tell you what i found but first
let's do an ad does it feel kind of
cheap i mean you're going to throw the
ads in i like that you might as well
just throw them in at a good cliffhanger
i i agree
um
we want you to check out stevie's
podcast best for you have not done it
best friends back all right the podcast
that she has with her high school best
friend they're reconnecting via podcast
in the episode that just came out is all
about
how stevie went from
stephanie yeah that's the name on her
id
to stephanie stevie
so there was a point uh in her high
school
where she went from stephanie to stevie
and she talks about that and nagin talks
about what it's like to grow up with a
name like nagin in a place like
greensboro yeah so that it's it's an
episode all about them processing their
identity
in high school and reprocessing it now
as part of them reprocessing their and
rekindling their friendship so
check it out if you if you if you like
that if you like
early 2000s nostalgia
if you like uh
if you like voices other than ours
they've got two great voices
check it out best friend's back all
right wherever you get your podcast
all right
so i'm looking
on his
uh desktop how do you search for this
well first of all it's a windows machine
and i'm like oh my gosh what do i do
it's like
look on the desktop for just stuff that
he's thrown there memoir
i don't know
and somehow i found what i what i call a
finder you know the explorer window
the file explorer i haven't used windows
in so long
and um i searched by
date edited because i thought it might
be one of the last things it was an
ongoing thing he worked on maybe one of
the last things he worked on
um
and i'm looking at
all the file names and it's stuff like
coaching tips and then there'd be things
you know instead of naming it it would
be like the first word of the document
like a lot of word documents
where it would be like um
don't quit
until or some and it would be like
the start of inspirational quotes would
be the names
of
these files because he was a he was a
coach for a really long time yes
and i started pretty successful coach in
in in several sports right
yeah and i i've got proof of that that
i'll get to in a second but yeah he
would
as a very committed basketball coach he
coached other things too but like
um
he
accumulate i would start opening these
things and it would be
um
quotes inspirational quotes and at first
i thought he was searching the internet
for inspirational quotes and putting
them in word documents
but what he was doing was pulling from
his memory of coaching
and
working under other coaches and being so
committed to the craft of coaching that
he had all these
pithy inspirational sayings
that then he would just he'd from memory
just start writing them down in word
documents
and then he would write things like
he would write his own name
and then he would write um like what's
it called like an anagram an acrostic
not an anagram he didn't worship satan
that's pentagram but oh pentagram uh
yeah so like he did all these word
document-esque inspirational coaching
exercises with his own name he even did
his own name wow do you remember that
one uh i'll have to look it up that's
awesome i know it's it just says a lot
about who he was as a person
that he was just like putting down the
paper all of these things that like he
he would say on the basketball court
to his to his teams and stuff you know
lovely excellent wonderful intelligent
and swell
that's lewis i i didn't email that one
to myself and then i came to one
that's that was called time line
time space line
not timeline two words timeline
i said this might be and i opened it up
and lo and behold here was a word
document it had a table of contents at
the top with like
um
years 1966 1969 1972 and it would say
like okay this is when he was in college
this is when he was in in service this
is when he had his first job so it was
like a table of contents
and then it was just
he then you go to down beneath it and it
would be like okay 1968 and then he
would have a paragraph sometimes three
paragraphs sometimes one sentence
and then he would go to the next one
1969 or whenever the next date would
show up
and so he talked about all types of
things
and
i would just love to share a few of the
things
that i found
in his timeline oh this is great because
it just it just shows you the type of
person he was that
at the very beginning he he gave an
intro he said it said 2017. so it was
like 1968 2017. he was like now before i
go any further
on all this i want to come back up here
and write this so it's like you could
tell he had written the whole thing it
was like four
it wasn't a tome this thing was like
four or five pages of word documents
okay
it was sketching out stuff that could be
made into a memoir
right okay
uh but he went back up to the top 2017
he was like
now
i want you to remember
it's not really about all of the
how did he put it
it's not really about all the things i
did
even though i'd
i experienced a lot of things it's about
all the people i met along the way
and so pay special attention to the
people i met
and then as you go through the whole
thing it wasn't his entire life it was
kind of like
if he were writing
a book for coaches
it was a lot it was like the highlights
of his life related to basketball
coaching some about teaching and then a
few stories that he's told to people
over the years that he he that he wanted
to put down on paper timeline a coach's
life yeah but it was more of it seemed
like the audience
i mean
definitely
his kids would enjoy it and
they did get a copy of it but it was
almost like did they know that this had
been happening no wow that's really cool
that they didn't know that this was
happening yeah i was able to remember i
was able to tell him find it and email
it to him and what i did was i'll say i
found it i read a no i read enough to
know that this was it
and then i stopped reading and i emailed
it to them
and i said here it is this is the thing
i didn't read all of it but
uh period
and i'm not going to share it with
anybody else
except
except mom
and then they wrote back and said
you know it's
uh
please read it
please read it and you know i'm not
going to read the whole thing here i'm
going to read some excerpts you're
you're saying you decided not to read it
i didn't want it i didn't i didn't know
if i should read it because he wasn't my
dad he's their dad yeah he's your
father-in-law i kind of wanted them to
tell me it was okay for me to read it
which they did and then i read it yeah
and of course i was going to give it to
mom i thought they would be fine with me
reading it i'm sure they would i just
wanted to cover my basis got it
legal legal purposes in 1969
he told the story of
getting drafted
into the the vietnam war because it was
1969. he was
um he they made you put down
uh a preference area like a like a a pr
like
what you would prefer to concentrate in
and he said well i don't you drafted me
you choose where i'm where i'm going to
go
and they said well you got to choose one
of these things you want are you
interested in infantry transportation it
was like transportation you know i grew
up on a farm i drive all types of things
i'll do transportation
and so
he tells the story i'm not going to read
it of
like everybody in the i'm sorry i don't
know the the actual term like the group
of 80 people platoon that are being put
through
basic training and then getting their
assignment like the vast majority of
people when they got their assignment it
was vietnam
but his
was
uh
washington dc and he was like there must
be some mistake
like two people out of all 80 oh it says
washington dc
and he goes up there and then i says
well you lucky duck you've been assigned
to be a chauffeur
at the pentagon
the vietnam war
you talk about dodging a bullet or mini
yeah it's like
he was and you know it was kind of he
was so he was he's very fortunate you
know and then he tells the story of
learning to drive every piece of
equipment in the army including like
tanks and stuff but then he was when he
got his assignment to go to the pentagon
he was driving uh senators and all
government officials and military
officials from the pentagon he said i
had to memorize everywhere in
washington d.c like the back of my hand
i knew washington dc better than i knew
lillington
so he's talking about that
he says
after a month in service moved
and i i want to read some of this to
give you an idea of how he wrote it
he wrote it like he was talking
after a month in service moved out into
an apartment behind the iwo jima statue
and enjoyed it very much
would go over to washington monument and
run to the top several nights a week
just for fun
it was a tough run
897 steps to the top
we would look out when we got to the top
then run back down
the run down was much easier than going
up
i think it was longer going up and
coming down
yep that's a joke because it was the
same route right that's that was what
made it funny yeah yeah
i'm tracking you're gonna you you gotta
uh get a ticket to go in there now
i know unless you're like i guess if
you're a soldier
and you have a uniform and you're like
you have access to like drive everybody
around maybe you can just go you have a
key and you can run it i mean i was just
there recently and there's a whole like
complex that's added to the side of one
part of it
where like there's security things that
you go through in a little gift shop
just think about it back then
during the vietnam war
he was running he was driving people
around and for exercise running to the
top of the washington monument multiple
nights a week
i mean you know it's i'll never look at
the washington monument not think of
that story
yeah your
papa you should run up run up to that
stuff and i remember he would tell us
that story
at some family gatherings
so it's cool that like those things made
it in here and a lot more
that i'm you know i'm not gonna read but
like he talks about talked about he
started coaching at cape fear christian
academy
and he taught the girls taught he
coached the girls basketball team and
they
um they made it to the state
championship
and lost but like he was a very
successful coach like
from the beginning like fresh out of the
military and uh
college
so he would talk about he would tell the
these stories of getting drafted of
things like that
but it was striking sometimes how he
would
really hone in on something very
specific
1976
bothered by pollen
from the mid 70s i was always bothered
by pollen my eyes would always turn red
and itch very bad i had to use many
bottles of visine
visine would just ease it off for a few
minutes but not long during the 70s and
80s i had to wear a mask while mowing
the grass
in the earlier 90s after my divorce
pollen bothered me for one year
it is now 2016 and it has not bothered
me in 15 years thank you lord
i have not had any treatment and do not
take any meds for it it just does not
bother me anymore
man that's awesome
it's like bothered by pollen yeah i mean
it's just
he was like this is just a strange
this is his way of saying
this is an inexplicable
potentially metaphysical or spiritual
thing that happened to me was i cured
of of pollen i would like to know
because you know me i go through a lot
of eye drops just
just to be on camera i've got to put in
eye drops or else everybody thinks i'm
high well uh it's maybe you just need to
get a divorce man
i mean let's read between the lines
uh i love you but we're getting divorced
because i'm bothered by policy
that's the only reason we can stay
together
we just need to legally divorce because
that might be the key 1982
taught math in prison for 12 years
what he's he took a job through central
carolina community college i know you
love cccc
um
they asked him to substitute teach at
the harneck county correctional center
aka the prison
and so he said i started
and i i quite liked it so i just kept
teaching there for 12 years
he writes
what's the difference between an inmate
and an outmate
the outmate is a person that has not
been caught yet
well
the students have sports just like we do
out of prison
because he he taught younger
kids and then he taught adults in the
prison
so when he talks about the students he's
talking well he's talking about all
prisoners the students have sports just
like we do out of prison i had a student
that was the weightlifting champion for
all of the eastern region of the us
a prison weightlifting champion he was
no he was a weightlifting champion
before he was in prison so this was a
huge guy
i had him for two semesters
after the two semesters he was back on
the yard
every morning as i came across the
prison yard he would meet me and ask
how's everything going
some mornings he would ask me if anyone
was giving me any trouble
after a year or so i asked him one
morning
why do you ask me that question
about every morning
he quickly answered me mr cummings i
don't want anyone to give you any
trouble or a difficult time you are fair
to all of us while in school and you
deserve the same if anyone gives you any
trouble you tell me
and i will take care of them at night
when they are not in school
they won't bother you anymore
wow sounds like he's saying hey just if
somebody's bothering you i'll kill them
yeah
that i mean that's what i'm
understanding from he says so i was
looked after in ways i didn't even know
he never told me until i asked why
he asked me almost every morning is
anyone causing any trouble
like the way he the way he'd write down
a story tie a bow on just to tie a bow
on it
in case you lost track he didn't let you
know it wasn't like i'm
he had these experiences
the way that he tells them is so
approachable is so true to who he was i
can hear him
saying these things you know a lot like
i said these stories some of them he
would tell us and he wrote them down how
he would tell them you know it wasn't
like
i gotta
i gotta i gotta make this some i gotta
make this in this more than it is i've
gotta
i gotta make this memoirable
you know it wasn't about the writing of
it it was about the experience of it
yeah and i love the fact that
nothing got in the way of him sitting
down at his computer
and writing this stuff down and it's
it's
it's such a treasure
he he kept going
and yes working with prisons was
different but it's that way in real life
people are all very different some
inmates and some outmates
you have to learn to work with all kinds
of people in real life it may be in
school job church community work
recreation factory etc
and i had the opportunity to work with
private school kids public school kids
parents coaches administration and
prisoners
youth prisons for three years in adult
prisons for nine years lots of great
experiences and worked with great
friends
staff and students
you know it's like
he had he had wisdom to share and it
didn't have to be
you know it didn't have to be souped up
yeah you know it just i just love the
fact that it just he it captured this
down-to-earth
wisdom
that he had that was any and the fact
that he was so good-hearted you know
every time that we
every time you saw him you know he had a
story to tell he had a smile on his face
you know it was like he was a special
guy yeah and he was and he and mom were
such a pair like that's the thing that
like mom and i were able to talk about
and remembering
because what i didn't tell you was
my mom said
can you print that off for me and i'm
like well your printer doesn't work and
i'm i'm not about to
start becoming your i.t guy that's not
the main thing i'm here for
but what i will do mom is i'll read it
to you
so i started reading it and like we
would start we we read through the whole
thing like i read it out loud to her she
was like this is kind of like a bedtime
story
and we got to talking about everything
that i was reading
that we couldn't get through all of it
in one night
and i had to stop and i was like mom
it's getting late you're going to have
to go to bed and she was like no no you
know it's just like putting a kid to bed
and so then the next night she was like
it got to be like 7 30 and she was like
you're gonna
you're gonna read some more to me we
gotta pick up where you left off last
night and i was like well i gotta charge
my phone first because we don't want it
to die in the middle of it and she was
like she had to wait like 30 minutes she
was so excited couldn't plug it in
couldn't put couldn't plug it in
i kind of wanted to mess with her i was
like we got to wait until it charges mom
but um
yeah it was it just struck me
when we went back through his memories
even though
she got one line in the whole thing
and it was like
the year of their second marriage
um
married for a second time
oh
wow so i got to that point in the thing
and i read it hold on i mean let me just
say as the guy who was not willing to
print it out for her but willing to read
it you could have embellished that
got married for the second time to the
love of my life but
by this point in the
in the reading of it i wanted to be true
to it and plus we both had an
appreciation like mom busted out laughs
she was like now i don't feel so bad
about giving her such a hard time right
writing a book
you know well i think it's because he
was ex he was actively experiencing a
relationship with her
and and the stuff that he was writing
down was a little bit more about like
yeah things he's remembering and it so
much of it was through the lens of like
teaching and coaching
and it was that world like 90 if it
wasn't about pollen
i mean he wrote one line about each kid
being born too i think i will say
bothered by pollen could is probably a
better name for the book than timeline
right it sounds like a robert frost
thing or something
part of me feels i mean
he wrote so many other things but
mom and i just got an appreciation for
how perfect they were for each other and
how
those 15
plus years i don't know how many years
do they have together
well you just said right there what year
did you say married for a second time
i didn't paste that into this i'm not
looking at the entire document in 2002
he talked about a near-death experience
he had where he almost got crushed by a
dump truck because he he had a dump
truck on his farm and he reached it was
up oh god and it was it was a tank full
of water
and then he reached his underneath it
to to pull out something he was like
like a dummy i pulled this thing that i
thought was a loose wire and it tripped
the whole thing and it's the whole
like
the hydraulic huge truck just like the
whole dump truck slammed down and the
next thing he knew he was standing
beside it and he did not know
what happened he just had a few scrapes
on his chest
but like he wasn't hurt
and like somebody walked by and they
said
what
louis
what happened to you
and he was white as a sheet
and lewis said
nothing
and then i said well you're white as a
sheet and he said
well i almost got crushed by this and i
don't know what happened but like his
original answer was nothing happened
because i guess technically nothing
happened right
but he talks about that near-death
experience and but that doesn't coincide
when he stopped being bothered by pollen
nope it's like that was 10 years later
yeah and then in 2010 he talked about
how he was diagnosed with polycythemia
vera which is like
you your body makes too much blood so he
had to go to the doctor and just
let leak a pint of blood every month or
so
but he said the way that he found out
was they were doing a bunch of tests and
they they started taking blood and he
said as the blood came out of the needle
it fell in the bag like ketchup falling
out of a bottle oh my gosh
it doesn't come out unless you squeeze
it
how did you read that without freaking
out i've i freaked out about it a bunch
but i've read this it's like thick blood
thick blood oh gosh that's when he
decided to retire
and like he moved into like he and mom's
phase of happiness together
but he had given up coaching for the
most part and
you know he signs the whole thing happy
happy happy thank you lord
happy happy happy was the duck dynasty
catchphrase that he modified into good
good good good yeah
and
you know there's so much more there that
you know is not it's not my business
reading any more of it publicly but i
just wanted to do that to honor him as a
person but it's you know you can see
what how this got me thinking
we should all be doing this
i mean if you you've got except
we should all be writing down the things
that
happened to us like he had these
memories treasured in his mind like
it was uh
um
just the things that what happened to
him like the way that he was drafted and
the near-death experience and the i
guess the pollen too it's like these
were all things that were like
and the people that he met and a lot of
coaches and basketball players that i
did not go into those details here were
things that were very important to him
and were kind of extraordinary things
that don't happen to a guy who
just is a farmer and a teacher in rural
harnett county right
so he had this sense that he lived a
full life
and it brought a tremendous amount of
comfort
to to all of us that read it his kids to
me to mom
um i read it to christy and my kids when
they showed up
like we went back through it it was like
we were able to celebrate it's like wow
he's
he really
had a he he had a lot of treasures
in terms of memories
you know so
this got you thinking
are you going to start writing
well for us
i'm like
that's kind of like the
i don't know the every man's application
but we're not every man we're weird
people
we're weird people who
have this conversation on the podcast on
a podcast and we've documented so much
of our lives here it was the type of
thing that again when you were week
before last
when you started talking about
talking about your your trip with lock
it's like you shared that with me
and on this podcast with everybody who's
listening
you're also sharing it with people who
would care to listen after you're gone
you know there's so much stuff out there
and so many stories out there in chia
lincoln and good mythical morning and
especially this podcast when we're
actively processing things that like
it we're storing up a bunch of treasures
here
but honestly i was like
there's no way my kids will ever
listen to this i mean it's like first of
all there's way too much of it it's not
like a word document that's like can be
emailed to you after i die
it's like do i make a after death
playlist do we need somebody to do that
it's like it's there's so much content
from us that it's overwhelming it's for
our audience now but then i start
thinking about what are my grandkids
going to listen to this
are my great great grandkids gonna
listen to this are they listening to it
right now
is does this does it mean anything to me
that to know that that's part of it do
you think this what is legacy i don't
know if this will make the playlist i
mean maybe this would make the the like
link history playlist because you're
talking about the playlist and it's only
appropriate that it's so it's so like
meta that this would make the playlist
so that means i'm on the playlist so
uh welcome to links uh
life
history playlist you're in so much of it
that people are kind of annoying i'm
sorry
i'm sorry but why do you insist on being
in everything that it is my leg you're
going to feel the same way about my now
this is my this is the one video that's
in both of our playlists right so
welcome to my playlist and i'm sorry
that he's here and even in the book of
mythicality we devoted a whole chapter
to
planning our funeral i'm not really
talking about planning the funeral in
our and our
um what's our obituary like we wrote
farcical obituaries
we try to we just embrace death in that
way and the humor of it on this side but
i'm talking less about that and more
about just
we put out so much information that our
loved ones could benefit
they can know us through all of this but
it's so much that i honestly don't think
it's just too intimidating
well it's too much
what it's so it's then it becomes
nothing
well well i don't necessarily agree with
that
uh it it makes me think a couple of
things one is
that
and we can come back to this in a second
i just want to throw this out there
because the first thing i think of is
what is the motivation for
uh a legacy like what is that related to
right what are we actually trying to
accomplish
second thing is
um i have thought about this aspect of
my kids my grandkids
just how people remember me
you know i tend
of course and most people who are
entertainment tend to think this uh to
some degree but we tend to think that
what we have to say is important
you know we're um
narcissistic enough
to
not maybe get diagnosed as a narcissist
but narcissistic enough to feel like we
could have a podcast and a show and a
so-and-so and what we're doing but i
don't think it's important i think it's
entertaining and engaging well but
connecting but what i guess what i'm
getting at is so
i just i have journaled
at different rates on and off for years
yeah but as we have transitioned more
into this podcast being so full of
self-disclosure and sort of story
summary and that kind of thing and also
the stuff that we've done on good
mythical morning over the years
the frequency and the detail
of
journaling has gone way down there was a
point in my life when i would
start writing in a journal entry and i
was definitely writing it as if someone
was going to find it someday like i'm
thinking about my my grammar and i'm
thinking about sounding
smart and eloquent and sounding like a
good writer
um
and that has really gone away which and
also you know with something like like
the trip that i took with locke but now
i was able to sit down within a week of
getting back
write down all the little things that
stand out in my mind as being compelling
to remember and to talk about and then i
talked about them for an hour and a half
or however long that podcast was
and so now i've kind of put it out there
and if i wanted to re-access it at some
point to remember what i because it has
there's a little bit of this like i'm
never going to remember it as precisely
as i did a week after it happened and
when i told the story so you think about
it in terms of
personal recall
you're never going to really no that's
one aspect it's just one aspect of it
but you but you don't but you honestly
don't think you're ever going to
re-listen to it right
no
no but i think that lock will
right i the idea that yeah you know
there i think there are certain pieces
where it's like okay after i'm gone
lock will listen to those two podcasts
of the two road trips that we had in the
you know the span of does he know you
they exist though yeah yeah he knows it
exists
okay um
i don't know if he listens to them now
he's an 18 year old kid who's got a
bunch of stuff going on he's like my dad
my stuff yeah
but he will
right he will at some point either while
i'm when i'm old or when i'm gone oh you
know what i'm saying
um so i do think about that but i
so i kind of feel like we've got it
covered in one sense now to answer your
question about the logistics of it
um
you're probably if you're interested in
this if you're like legitimately
interested in somebody doing this i do
think it's like
uh like a paid intern
working
for literally months
to take
everything that you've ever said about
yourself
and
put it into
like a playlist or i
edit it together yes i think that that
could be a worthy exercise
if you want to like catalog your life
because you've talked about so much your
life and then you know they would
probably get one intern to do both of us
but
so i do think the only way it's just so
intimidating is to like have a curated
guide to
link's dead and you want to be sad about
it but you want to also be happy about
it and you want like i think this is a
good this i think a sampling is enough
sampling i mean i think
i i think you get i mean we kind of say
the same types of things over like a guy
you know
it's like oh yeah some funny things
happen i don't think it's i to me it's
like there's one thing that's like the
process of
mourning
and letting go and but celebrating and
hanging on to
um who like in this case who louis was
as a person who he was to me who he was
to mom
um
who he was to students and prisoners and
you know it's
it it really
it it it coalesced in my brain like
everything kind of came together
like i wish i would have read it while
he was alive and we could have talked
about it you know it's like when he said
i'm writing it
you know yeah it was like let me read
what you got but it i don't you know
it's just one of those things where it's
like okay it's a work in progress
but
i i do think that
there's another way to think of it so
that's one place to think about it
is that
hey i'm
i'm mourning i'm remembering and i'm uh
not just eulogizing but um commemorating
so i feel like
my love for for louis is kind of
commemorated in this in this experience
of reading this thing but there's
another experience that i think about
it's like
my grandkids kids
oh yeah it's like you know back when
videos used to be on the internet and
like this is how technology used to work
your great great grandfather you know
that guy who's like
he's so old he's he's he's scary to look
at do you think you're gonna have great
great grandkids oh yeah i'm gonna get
some sort of elixir yeah man
okay well
yeah i guess you're right the dead the
dead guy you know the one that's just a
brain in a vat yeah were the glasses on
the outside of the glass yeah who knows
how i'm still gonna stick around grandpa
link or i'm gone and it's like
you can watch these things it's like
you're gonna have to get us a different
type of screen and it's not gonna be
downloaded to your brain
i know it's going to be frustrating but
and you have to scrub through it on this
old device or something or i don't know
maybe it's been brainitized well you
make a good point because if they could
just download all the history
to their
brain then they actually don't have to
watch it then watch all that content
talking matrix yeah download but i think
that's another use case um i've been
thinking about this all of this crap is
that like
all this all this content that we're
putting out into the world it's like
what if i mean what if you were i don't
know it would be like
watching
like if andy griffith was my
great-great-grandfather and i'm like
wait you got to watch this this show
called the andy griffith show and like
he was a comedian and he made this
sitcom
what's the sick okay don't worry about
it just watch it you'll you'll
find it my question
is
why right so what is the motivation for
us as a as living people who are trying
to leave a legacy
um
[Music]
once we're dead and what is the
motivation
or what do you think the purpose
ultimate purpose is for someone who's
left behind to read it because i i was
thinking about yeah you know i was
recently thinking about my grandfather
my
um
dad's dad now both of my grandfathers
my dad's dad
who i met just a couple of times in my
life
uh
and then
my mom's dad who i never met because he
died when my mom was in college
and then i had like a st you know step
granddad uh who was the closest thing i
had to a granddad but you know
but
i've been thinking about them
the ones that i didn't know well and i'm
just like i want you know everything i
know about them is through the lens of
my parents
and then and i found myself wondering
like what were they really like and how
much of it has been shaped by just the
perception that my parents had and then
i was like why
why why like what do i want to know
about them why do i want to know that
because you feel a connection there's a
blood connection to like there's part of
my dna
that was in this guy i am who i am at
least in part because of them sure think
about if you could watch
a video a one hour and a half video of
your
grandfather
talking about
his his struggle with spirituality you
know it's like that would be fascinating
and i mean just to say
look at his mannerisms like i
i do that
you know i sound like that
like i have this instinct to
to talk about things in this way and so
did he it's like all of a sudden you
have this like connection of lineage
like i've never i've never really been
one i'm not one of those family tree
people like i've i've just never been
inspired to look into lineage and
but that is fascinating and if and if
there was a video of a great my
great-grandfather if we could just get a
video
in his in his internet prime talking
about it i'd be like i gotta see a
little bit of that of course i would
love to i would love to experience that
from
long dead relatives but then maybe you
get some sort of like
insight because there's there's wisdom
to me it's like is there
wisdom that could be passed down a few
more generations because so much has
been
uh recorded of us i would hope so
especially on ear biscuits but there's
also a lot of us cutting a fool
that's like
would just be a trip to watch found this
funny it's like what yeah people find it
funny but some people did there's a lot
of people did like all of the stuff that
we eat on good mythical morning is like
it's a preservation of pop culture
you know in in a way that there's fewer
i mean there's other videos that got it
but like in terms of like a complete
catalog
of
like pop culture
especially when it comes to food like
snacks think about like you know you we
go on ebay and get all these old
discontinued snacks
and
eat them from you know decades ago
but like think about
a century from now
we
we are conveying an experience of
eating snacks
from
the
2010s
2020s you know it's like is that
valuable to like the library of congress
i mean
they they put like
wu-tang clan
in the national archives
like
i kind of feel like maybe one day we'll
be in okay but here's my question
the gmn will be in the national archives
but
you know
for eating eating
snacks but why do we want that to be i
just think that's cool i don't want that
to be the case but no but don't i mean
you kind of do that i'm not doing it for
that reason because i just thought of it
well no but no but i'm just saying what
is the motivation to
yeah okay there's an altruistic version
which is like maybe my
descendants will gain some
insight about themselves yes of course
that's awesome sins of the father type
thing that that's it yeah yeah yeah
that's rewarding
but don't you think that everyone has
a tendency to want to be remembered and
it's the same
thing that keeps you wanting to be alive
we don't want to die
we don't want to go away
and
lots of people probably the majority of
people in the world definitely the
majority of the people in the world
believe that they will continue to exist
in some form after they die
i don't know what i think about that
obviously everyone wants to continue to
exist
um
but what if we what if this
expression of consciousness
is
contained in this lifetime
and then it's over
first of all there won't be any ego post
death
to appreciate or relish in the fact that
you are being remembered
you know
lock and i had this interesting
conversation
uh on our road trip now that i think
about it that is strangely related to
this
because he he essentially asked the
question i don't remember the specifics
but it was
you know
would you if you could choose like your
your life is going to be great and
you're going to get to do the things
that you want to do and accomplish the
things that you want to accomplish and
live a long life
but like five years after you die
your reputation is going to be ruined
because they find something out about
you even if it didn't happen but just
like let's just say that somebody says
something about you that wasn't true
but your name death smear campaign your
name becomes associated with just like
oh we don't talk about we don't talk
about grandpa because so and so okay
and locke was like what
i mean i'm just saying like if you okay
if somebody came to you right now and
said you can have what you want you can
have health and life
and but the trade off
but just let you just so you know five
years after you die okay yeah i got it
um
i'll tell you what i said after
my knee-jerk reaction is i would go for
it i just feel like that the reputation
is overrated i
i'm just concerned about how it might
impact my progeny's opportunity well
that's what i told him i said the first
thing that comes to mind is
i don't want your life and shepherd's
life and your mom's life to suck to suck
because you're a smear campaign yeah
but if you remove that so let's just say
it's
five generations later
your name is going to be synonymous with
like something crazy hateful or just
whatever
how does it make you feel like if you
okay
lot was like i don't care because i
won't have the ability to care
but yeah but
really if you could choose if you could
choose and let's say nobody that
currently you love and know is going to
be affected but five generations from
now
are you really telling me that you don't
care about your name being smeared i
have to know what am i choosing against
you gotta tell i mean like just a a
crappy life a horrible life
no no i'm changing the scenario now and
saying that
come to you and i say five years from
now
i mean five generations from now after
you're dead either
you're gonna be your name's gonna be
remember for what you did or there's
gonna be a smear campaign you're
obviously gonna choose what you did but
why
why do you care because one thing is
like do you care or i only have
something to gain i guess is my point
what what do you have to gain yeah you
won't exist the knowledge now that i
won't be smeared five generations from
now right but even when i think about
things like
i don't want to
die naked or something you know what i'm
saying like i don't want to die in an
embarrassing way
like when you think about oh man if i
die and i'm wearing this pair of
underwear that i just took a crap in or
something
you don't i there's a part of me that's
like my ego
feels like it's trying to reach past my
existence
okay you know and so
i say all that to make the point to come
back to what we're talking about which
is
it's difficult for me to separate that
tendency for my ego to want to live
beyond my consciousness
uh
from
my desire to leave a legacy because it
it
it is a lot about me
and then i kind of end up being in this
place where i'm like i have so much
to be thankful for in terms of
so much of what i've done and said in
the things that i'm proud of are out
there
and i don't really have to think about
this like i don't have to think about
what my memoir would be because it's
kind of already being written
i i don't so it sort of takes care of
itself for me i get excited about
my
uh great grandkids who would never know
me or know me as this old
guy who might be an invalid or something
or great
great grandkids who will never know me
being able to
know me in a sense and say you know what
i could have been i could be i could
have been friends with that guy
i don't know that just it just seems it
just warms my heart a little bit and i
think there's to know there's legitimacy
in that yeah it's like it but it's so i
don't think about like on a societal
level like i just
i know that we're doing good work i know
it it has a positive impact on people
and i
when i say it i do start to think and i
guess get excited about that like you
know
some people would still have this taste
for it
you know generations from now they might
i you're probably right they would watch
good mythical morning and like say you
found this funny you found this
entertaining
but maybe that's not true i could sit
down and watch the andy griffith show
and right now and be
my heart could be warmed by that
you know so that does make me happy
but in terms of like
i guess now i'm in such a familial zone
you know with coming off the funeral and
everything
i'm thinking a number of things which is
like
i'm not
i'm thinking more about dying than
living forever
you know like
death with dignity type thing and i
started to have those type of thoughts
but but also
um
people who
yeah like generations like family
members
being able to have some connection with
me and gain some wisdom
from me that like i would just hope that
they could glean somehow through the
reading between the lines and i don't at
this point i don't think there's there's
not
i completely agree and i don't think
there's anything wrong with that and i'm
not trying to say that
the element of ego that is in what you
just said as well is a bad thing it's we
can't help i mean
sure the fact that we want to leave a
legacy that is positive
is a good thing that's built into the
human psyche
because if it wasn't then you would do
some crazy [ __ ] right at the end of your
life just because you know what i'm
saying like we actually want to die most
people
want to die well want to leave a legacy
um and i think that
because you have the ability to think
about the future benefit that someone
else will receive
and even if it makes you feel good
because oh i'm proud of that i could
leave a legacy that they will benefit
from i don't think there's anything
wrong with that
it's just those are the things that come
to mind when i think about
um
you know
that can be taken too far there's like
an unhealthy level of that when you're
like so concerned about what you're
doing and how people will remember you
in ways that you know it's the old adage
you can't take
anything with you
you know never seen a
uh a hearse with a
with a u-haul attached to it
you can't take anything with you but you
can leave a lot oh
you know i've heard that before
who told you that not you
but i also like the idea of
okay
when i die i would i would love to know
that there are still some mythical
beasts out there who are active enough
you know hopefully i'll die a long time
time from now so it'll be surprising
that there's like mythical active
mythical beasts who are like
putting together a
you know just like a montage well people
still watch like golden girl i just want
to you know put down but i will still
watch golden girls for like comfort i
have to believe that somebody out there
is going to watch gmail
but i believe that there's that there
will be fan montages that will be passed
around on whatever version of the
internet exists in the future hopefully
the distant future
after i pass
and they
the bit the sadness of the experience of
me being gone will be
overwhelmed and eclipsed by
the comfort in knowing that
i lived a
i lived my life to the fullest and
uh they connected with it
i agree but i wholeheartedly that does
it does feel good to know that that will
happen
but one interesting thing there's a
closing thought that might make this all
very unsettling for you
is that our legacies are
linked
is uh inextricable is that a word yeah
whoever doesn't die first so like if you
if i die
and you do something that is if you just
tarnish your legacy you tarnish my
legacy because people can't
you know and how did we solve this in
the book of mythicality by rev there was
when you read the obituaries you realize
that one of us inadvertently killed the
other one right through like some
strange
that's how we solved it uh but that's an
interesting thing is that
so much of what people experience from
from you and your what your great great
grandkids experience it's like they're
go they are forced to experience me as
well
and we
you know we we basically have that
responsibility for one another whoever
dies first
you gotta you know to make the playlist
well to hire an intern to make the
playlist yes but what i'm saying is to
make sure that the legacy is not
tarnished
i'm saying you know and i'm taller so
i'm probably going to die first so this
is probably on you okay yeah i'm not
worried about it that's my that's my
word
that's my worry sorry if i'm not present
yeah man and like you know maybe there's
a live stream at some point now you know
how christy feels every day when i come
to work like 30 years from now
something comes out what's he gonna do
at work today on a live stream and you
tarnish yeah our legacy and i'm just
like
i'm up there in heaven
damn it i can't do anything about this
oh but you're watching it yeah i'm
watching all night link tv and you're
seeing all of it
so write your own timeline if you if you
want to if if you were inspired to do so
bothered by pollen let us know um about
your experience with pollen hashtag your
biscuits
no what what i mean what does this make
you think of how do you how are you
processing this is it
is it making you cringe is it giving you
ideas i i really don't know that's why
hashtag ear biscuits exists and why do
do you want to leave a legacy what kind
of legacy do you want to live leave and
why
oh gosh we got deep there's got to be
more of these podcasts hashtag air
biscuits um do you have a wreck i do
have a wreck
not related to anything switch it up um
i am going to recommend a hot sauce
okay
it's a hot sauce that i've been putting
on multiple things this is exciting this
is different uh it is
marie sharps
now she has a whole lot of different
stuff the original
the original hot sauce which is pretty
daggum hot
it is uh from belize
and it is habanero and in belize they
add carrots
to the hot sauce which gives it a
really good flavor now let me say
something about this and you may
remember when ten dollars on amazon
much cheaper than that in the grocery
store and it's probably available in
most grocery stores
when we did a hot sauce taste test on
good mythical morning we tried melinda's
hot sauce and josh said this at the time
i don't know what made it to air
but the story of this hot sauce is that
this woman marie sharp was in belize and
her husband was a farmer he was growing
habaneros and she started making hot
sauces out of it
everybody's like this is great
what we're going to make we want to
start selling your hot sauce and she
says i want to call it melinda's and it
was like named after the farm or
something on the farm
the company that she was working with
copyrighted or trademarked melinda's and
started melinda's the hot sauce company
which is actually bigger than marie
sharps and sells a bunch of hot sauces
and we had it on the show and that's why
i feel a little bit bad about this and
basically
took this woman for a ride
and so you're trying to make it right
and then marie sharp
was like i gotta go back and start from
scratch and i'm gonna make my own hot
sauces and now she makes her own hot
sauce and she has a bunch of different
varieties again i like the original
and she has reasons for why she thinks
hers is better than melinda's i actually
haven't tried them side by side but just
out of principle
i'm a marie sharps man
and it is spicy but i've been putting it
on i've been putting it on
everything
and i just love it it's got a complex
flavor and some heat
um so i think probably any of the
varieties are great but if you're gonna
get started somewhere start with
just the original hot i love how the in
the bot the white right wrapped a bottle
the bottle says
gives a lot of the story of how she
makes it but the last sentence is
produced in the fertile paradise of
belize her red habanero is considered to
be the hottest of pepper known to man
well last question well that's not true
marie has spent many years cultivating a
habanero worthy of her recipe
she has succeeded
[Laughter]
she has succeeded there's just something
about she has succeeded something about
it marie sharpe's house it's got her got
her picture on the side of the bottle
too i love that
all right
marie calendar i mean marie shart i
believe you will enjoy it hashtag ear
biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]